I hope you're doing well and I have this
little guy there, he's the one who's going to make
the presentation, that tells you, we'll
try to make him work later on,
even if he's a little
capricious with the  its but i'm going
to use it later for a demo
it's going well so we're going to talk about clash
functions claude sanchez which is the
cloud platform server solution leaves compu
that we released not very
long ago which is still in progress  beta I am
guillaume laforge am a developer
advocate for google cloud platform I
joined google a little
over a year and a half ago and so I have the
pleasure of talking mainly about
complete solutions among other things
but everything  first of all what
is this keyword this buzz word of the
server day leaves well I'm going to introduce you to
the new
google datacenters no servers okay no so
obviously it's not that there's no
servers in
google's new datacenter milks but it's just
that  you don't care
so it's google that manages the servers
that manage all this
infrastructure
so when we talk about relay servers
it's really all about service
completely management and you just have
to focus on your
business logic you applications that you are
going to deploy on the platform and all
the other aspects finally there is
no provisioning etc and it is google
which manages all that for you do
we still have concerns that  whether it's
security level installing the latest
patches on the servers whether it's
how to properly configure a batch of
sister whales in short there are a lot of
things that will be managed
automatically by the platform so
if we look a little bit on this
timeline
s  so they have before the cloud before the
server is and the
toddlers improve it our little
caveman but google is not at
its first attempt either with 7
this notion  n of servers leaves even if
at the time it was not necessarily called
servers leaves we started all the same
with barely jean in 2008 a man who
had barely jean for python in 2008
and the java version in 2009 me I have
barely started playing with jean in
2009 with the java version and I lost
my blog for example it's an
app engine application that I've been using
since 2009 not changed a
bit between 2009 2010 but in short
for seven years or so  something
like that i don't care about server
or anything i'm deploying a
new version of my application and
i'm very happy that google
takes care of that for me after so
we released other products  very
interesting is also completely
manager don bigg prairies for everything
that is analytics data warehouse and
serra cloud storage to do
storage we just have to send our
files datastore datastore
initially it was part of dap and
jean but we have it  also extracted so that
they can be reused
by other service cars
other other applications etc
cloud data flow to manage your
pipelines badge streaming
with data flow on a fire bay for
everything  is mobile involvement where it
is it's with the realtime database
for purposes a whole bunch of
pretty innovative applications pops up for anything that
's public either that crab over
messages clac functions that we're going to cover
today  'today and then also for example the
machine learning and jean which
actually allows you to deploy your
machine learning models directly on
the google infrastructure are
once again having supplied
anything from the servers of the kloster etc
it's still  once the infrastructure
and manage for you so whether it's
for training models or
running predictions
another big feature an
important feature of server approaches comfortable
is  really the world pop game in
French they pay for itunes go so you
useful you pay for consumption so
if you don't even use in fact you
pay nothing and if you use a lot in
proportion to what you
use a lot will follow
this curve most particularly
we what will interest us
today breaks down function so
the different attributes that we have already
mentioned no need to worry about
pay as you go servers but the two
nice characteristics that we will
also cover are the approaches
event-oriented everything that is
asynchronous or synchronous too since we
can also do synchronous with the
functions
and then the deployment unit goes it's
more an application for example like
on barely jeans but it's a function
a micro service  in the form of a function
so why is it important we are going to
take a small a small example
let's imagine a fairly classic way
of doing things a system  e of
reservation we will have orders
arriving there we have a vm running which
processes its orders there we will send its
orders which are stored in the
google cloud storage very well afterwards well
we will perhaps have certain things to
do  we will add related services
for example indexed all the documents
we have received we will be able to add
and then store this information these
indexes in a database we will
also manage everything related to networks
we will take care of  authentication
which has a lot of things to do
and imagine later another part
of our application set which arrives
which will process the invoices this time
which will also store them in
cloud storage but where we will
certainly have others
similar services or possibly see the
same ones
that we will have to add and then after
my risk perhaps possibly
of having versioning problems
between its different services
they will perhaps  be duplicated so
if there is a problem on the right it will
have to be corrected on the left and
it is therefore not necessarily ideal
that we can do better
what can we do so we can
say to ourselves we are going to centralize its
related services with a nice a nice api will
send all this information there to
the country
the country will take care of the storage
afterwards to upload the information in google
cloud storage the services we will be able
not to duplicate them  but really
letting them factorize them centralize them
after good it is already a more interesting approach
a micro service for that for that for that
on the other hand after if the country can
possibly become the the
weak point the weak link of this
architecture the silla country  tamba
nothing else works when we
might want to work anyway
possibly in a degraded way and
but who is at least certain of the
services that they can work
so we can do better we  can try
to think in terms of donations that we
continue like that to store in cloud
storage but in fact act according
to events so there is an event
holds cloud storage has stored
something in cloud storage
there is an event which is launched  and in
fact the functions will be able to
we will come to the functions but
the application application that we
had earlier at the bottom will be able to process
these events and take care of its
documents store them and it is to have
the associated services that we have that we
listed earlier
after that's not bad huh, on the other hand if
we try to think about skis and skis and
use so there we have name magic
that we're sure that  'we point engine we are going to
have big vms to process the
two applications on the left and on the right well
there we know the cpu gauge
here we really use all the
potential all the power of the vm
on the other hand maybe only with the  same vm
for other related services in
fact there is  maybe not so much traffic
necessarily not so many loads so
much business logic that is applied
and suddenly we wear out maybe uses cvm
there is in fact all this gray part
that we see either on the left on the right or
in the whole below it is
something that has been provisioned for which
we pay and the idea would be
to optimize its and perhaps have a
smaller beer or on the contrary
to have a function-oriented approach
where finally the function we are going to pay
only for this use of the
function but we do not provision anything
therefore to nothing there are no small
small rectangles grid in a
way
here are some terms some
explanations what we tend
to towards  tender with claude frantzen clac
function
it is our server environment
today is based in any case on our djs
and event-oriented javascript
so either with direct invocations
with http calls or with
events from the clo  ud
whether it's things that come to
cloud storage on people and so it's
the new function-oriented
micro-service-oriented architectures and
it's finally we're going to see a whole bunch
of events that will come perhaps from the
cloud
perhaps-  being from external services we will
see our functions asynchronously
or synchronously with http which processes all
these events these events there then in
turn the functions can
possibly call other
functions or also write as
we had earlier  hour for example the
indexing data write them in
so in there datastore
call other external services etc
so we couples we avoid the
strong coupling with the country that we had at the bottom
just now and we separate the
things in independent function so
functions that scale
independently
possibly so it's not
scanning so it can be stalled here it is
until reindeer but we don't talk we
also think  at skelling up to 0 so
if we don't use these functions there we
obviously don't want to pay
for its functions since we haven't
used them are isolated from each
other
it's also an approach states  and
ephemeral
we need the function hop it is
there but as soon as we no longer need it
goodbye what is interesting suddenly
is that depending on your the
way your applications your
functions are to access the platforms it
maybe there will be one instance of a
function another time there
will be 100 because there will really be a
spike in traffic and it's going to be done
transparently
so both types of functions there
are http functions  so there it's a in
fact it's an invocation gives you
when you deploy a function you are
given a url a certificate and so
that's why it's functions
that we call through https so
the url certificate https and the other is
the other during these
backgro functions  und works so it's
really the functions that works
in five rounds and there are
cloud events a new file including clac
storage etc
we're going to look at what
the http functions look like so s carnac have
already done node js du  javascript in
the room yeah we have a lot of half we'll
say so we export our function which
has an input request we have a dream the
manager has in this ultra
simplified version we're just going to answer
here's hello the equivalent of hello
world and the  clac summit de parisse
then have this function once
we have developed it we can deploy it with
the online tool
so there is not only this means there but
we can doubt to deploy it
using the command gicle  hard what
there is the
we deploy the function called hello
world that we had we had done our
export the state beckett and in fact we up
the aude the sources we package these
sources finally it's done
automatically
my us package is safe  e this there is a
budget that is used to recover and
installed in clac works your
function and we specify pull pull
trigger http because it is a
syncrude function triggered by http a
call to the url http s as for the functions
never know how  we say background
french de d'background I'm leaving it
's a little weird I find
background the asynchronous functions
so there are two ways to do so
already noted the signature which changes a
little bit
so in fact these functions and take
a  event so there you have the details
so for example if it's a message
people you know the topic if that but
it's a file on cloud storage you
know where for what purpose kate
will be
the file the silk you have  a call
back so once the function finally
that the processing is done you
can call the bac pole to notify
the plan or else we can also
use the javascript promises so
there is only one  parameter to the
function and we return also finds the
promised it was how it should be the
net was filled there both cases so
it's the same thing except in bold the
trigger so the trigger is trigger
beuquette when  it's an event
coming from something that is safe
cloud storage and trigger topic by
indicating the topic
when it's a message that we receive on
a particular topic in cloud pub
afterwards so it's very nice we
programmed but we  wants to look anyway at
what is happening so with in
particular the tooth there we will see we will see later
anyway in the demo
at best than on this little drawing here
so we obviously take advantage of
the interface of the  cloud console of gc
pays so we have access to this driver tag
so as soon as we do
point log consoles in our javascript
all these messages they will arrive in
this taxi driver login so we can
see them directly which is not bad
also I  see where we play will show it
in the  demo but when you can
also see the logs associated with a
particular function call, everything which is
quite practical when you see that such a
call fails and fails for example and
where you want to see the information that you have
lobbed with console blog  we will be able to
see this detail then if there are
exceptions of things that we have not been
caught with trail catches etc.
we will see them arrive on the style driver
errors side and then c log
we will be able to access them so either
directly  in the console in iowa
where with
the other the command line squirts hard
or also with the rest of the country we will
also be able to do a little bit of
monitoring so in the
cloud functions interface in the console we will be
able to see the  the invocation name will be
able to see it the execution time
the memory usage
the environment in which your
functions actually run it's a linux
debian 8
jesse hall use our -js 6 dots
11.1 or unless  they have a
newer version m  But normally I do
n't want to be wrong about two versions there are
also some things that are
preinstalled, for example email magic
in the demo that I want to show later
I manipulate images
and I use the node module for
imagemagick but imagemagick  has already been
installed on this environment there
we also have access during the execution of the
function in fact to a kind of
ephemeral disk slash tmp it is a kind of
ram disk in fact so its room uses
the memory that you have to  rent to your
function and a super practical thing and
which allows you to have code that is also
clearer more readable in fact when you
imagine have like me I'm going to do
it later I'm going to call
services for example watch I  I don't
need words so proud of
the apei
but I am automatically authenticated
my function is automatically
authenticated so my code what we
think you really do that we will
say that
the business value of  2 of the 100 kg code is
a little bit the crocs skating like
only the the elements in English sorry
the finally all that is
authentication or other we don't
need to worry about it
thanks to that and then yes if so  your
node js code also needs modules
that are native they will be conquered
the native way on the platform
directly so suddenly you don't
need
imagine me I'm here I have a mac here
I'm compiling on my
machine
I see that on one on a debian the
code that I would have compiled will probably
not work that's why it's
done on the side of the platform when we
develop what is good to use here
it  is we have a clac
functions emulator so it's you
can use it with the npm
install command which will install in fact you
will have a command line tool which will be
called fangshan which you can
use and which has the  same the same
commands in fact as when we make
cl  oud apps diploma but it deploys
locally which is interesting
so even if when we deploy a
new version our function it
still deploys relatively
easily 30 seconds a minute
but when we sometimes make small
mistakes or we often retouch
its  code it can be quite painful to
redeploy each time on the other hand what
we can do is to use
precisely this emulator which is
completely compatible with
the apei of cloud ventures and which allows
him on the other hand to make the
loadings live so  as soon as I make
changes in my buddy
they are automatically available and they are
visible and one thing that I
often do in development mode
in fact is to use also there is a
small tool called and rock here it is
I'm not going to show it in
demonstration but there is a little tool
they call a cave which allows you
to actually make tunnels between a
url given to you by and rock and
fair  e a kind of bridges of tunnels to
your machine locally so for example
if google the man is friendly with
me
box the demo at the very end when I
say deployed when I say
deploy pages I was developing sorry my
application which was good  it was
that I had the live reload is it called
my machine so I develop
quietly on my machine also
what is interesting is the aspect of the
bug
so either you can then it
also integrates with the ide but  we can also
use chrome dave coles and
see the integration of the deal bug
directly in chrome and you then there
are different modes in addition we can even
debug the emulator itself I already
had to do it when I  had found a
bug in the emulator
but otherwise it allows you to
effectively unlock your functions directly
and to have the breakpoints and
this is what can be very very practical
so at the deployment level so I
said for example  in line  control
with jean clade but we also have a small
editor integrated directly into the
console so we can paste directly
like that afterwards good when we're doing
it's good in development mode afterwards
to test things but when we
want a little bit  industrialized the
developments and that they are a
minimum serious obviously the
source code of our functions we will be able to
store it in github and by using
cloud it would be positive but also to do
the mirroring with peter pan it is
github to unlock anything else or to
use directly  claude source very
positive
and to see the changes that are taken
into account according to the source code which
obviously stored in so for versio
born your code so there I'm going to
show you my little demo then first
of the good ones so let's imagine images you
have plenty of  photos and we will
store them in google cloud storage as soon
as a photo arrives at montils
raccoons and who will arrive in the
cloud  storage is going to have an event
this event it is going to
finally call a function is going to be notified of
this event there it is going to take my
image and I am going to call life I have no
prime to find out what is
in this image with the  life I have
it have it have it will give you
what are the labels what
was found in this photo we will see
I don't know what I took as an
example I have to see some images on
my computer we  will see what they find us
what they find us first
treatment second treatment so good
there it is well found it is a rack or
pro on the idea and I think it is a
mammal and its first treatments
second treatment another  function
will also be invoked but this
time what I will do with this
function there in fact and I will use
the image of the magic which is due after
installed on the acquired debian which
runs on which runs the clotte
actually works  I will be able to do
too  i have thumbnails of my images
so that's my two treatments and
then so whether it's the labels finally
the gie zone same game
kim returned by there young people and
pia wherever it is here the thumbnails I
put the results directly in
cloud storage and we could
imagine other treatments that are
done afterwards because I applauded the results
there so we're going to see that concretely so
we're going to go to my machine
[Music]
thank you so there I'm in the interface
in the console it's fine it's quite big
we can see where I may also have
a little bit more so here I am in my
project raccoon function it's a great
name that period project name I have two
functions  so as we saw there from a
small diagram so there is one that
will do the resizing of the images
it is the noise size and extra club that will
call life I drew from it so we will
look at which one  first maybe
go resize we will start with this
one hop whip  so there is not
much there I had to call it earlier
we see that my function is not very
often called but at least it
costs me nothing since not many
called so we have here I  told you earlier
so in the interface
we have for example the number of
sion lawyers so there it doesn't have much
execution time it's the same it does
n't take a lot of time since for my
tests I did not invoke them a lot we
see because yes and precisely there when
I had developed
I had errors we will look at that well
we will start with that first and
for example an error that I had not
caught and  beats automatically I can
go and see the
so it is caught by stack driver
error reporting and I can have it
directly afterwards so if I want to see
the logs too then I think
I put them here I can also see the logs
so each time  time my function is
called I can see the detail for
example that was someone ago  the days
I had problems
and what was it yeah because
I didn't have a bible and the use
of viewing it and looting so we
find here are all the
usual stack driver services which are good
practices
what do I not yet have 10 on the
functions therefore the invocation the execution
the memory use
we have some details in which region
finally when was it deployed
the regions the memory etc
here the trigger months show rigor
is when I put something in
the cloud storage beuquette in
this case and my image input bin is
here I will be able to see my code
so there are two things we will find
or so I will  put in edit mode
so that we can put it on the big screen
so here you go when we create
or there when we edit a function the
only thing finally that we can
define is the size of the memory
because it is  true that some
treatments can take a long time
memory or not a lot so the only the
floor how would i say
the only thing we can update
we'll say it's finally the only control
we have over what they perform our
functions is the size  memory the
triggers so this is where I defined
the input bucket and we therefore have here either I
can edit there this is what I did in
any case for the demo directly in
the interface or I can  plots unzip
same incident what a shame the storage
too or use cloud it would be
positive and possibly github guide
etc
there we if we press the little icon we
will see what is happening in code
so I need some modules
then passed to manage  so there I
defined them in isen package moreover not
if I don't see it blue bird it's for
the first ones that hop and so here is my
function is here that's what I'm going to
export in fact at the end I jump
directly the end the age exports that
as we modulate my function is here there
it takes an event so  there I am
in promised mode either the resource
exists it does not exist I retrieve the
name of the file that was put in cloud
storage since I have a file I will
make a require on the node module to
process cloud storage I  going to be able to
log things so i get them
pointing to the bucket the file the
path also the the thumbnail that i
'm going to create i'm going to set a new
path for that so
when here i'm actually going to download the
file from cloud storage into my
in my file system in a
disk that was local and then here
then we are going to do my
resize function this is the details of the resizing
that I am going to do the paths the
sizes and then after what we are going to do
hop a story of  kate
it's in there where we're going to implode the
result that we're going to log things and
so that's that's the first function
and then the other functions that I had
it's extraordinary board which is  here
also look at the source code
a pop up and says that here let's
take about the same things here on the
other hand I'm there will say if
it's which wells and lynx three clubs
at that's right I'm not mistaken and
we'll call in  watch it
squeal with teeth here
I avoid young people who are here and I'm going to
call the dect ac method detect the
boys 1 of abyei town to
retrieve what's in my function
and then in fact we're going to store  the
home zone after in the in the bin
is back so we're going to see that
concretely hop I'm going to go to my
cloud storage here so I have there it's here
in fan things only work at
the jean bacquet stadium actually  my code
and automatically packaged here I'm going to
put the images and in the other
before becoming add something this is
where I'm going to put the
thumbnails and then the labels
found there life so I don't have imagine foot
I  gonna upload and hop to more files
so what do i got what i got  an
interesting thing what is it is a
frenzy of boxes
come on let's take this one so there
jean-claude my file here we can
look at what this image looks like
this is the big image of wooden boxes
so  there was an event i stored
my picture there was an event that was
started i will look in the other
kate beckett release is normally
then brought in pictures and we should
have boxing here the home neil name i  I
created two brought there here he is very
small it is an image 100 by 100 we
see the small pixels and then in this
file the free to the big ones it is a little
bit we will see what he has  found
furniture goodstein chestov jones
antique
so here are the labels that
found it so what is nice
here here we have defined functions
a little bit independent of each
other which will react to an event
several functions can react to the
same events and processes
can be realized  asynchronously
there is another small demonstration
I didn't necessarily go into much
detail but which I like very much
I have my colleague sara who made a
demo which is very nice or in fact and
takes so it's  the same approach but
with different api opened take
I'm going to show it to you and
even maybe here directly or in fact
she created an application with
different videos we're going to take these
videos so
let's imagine
we upload a video to google cloud
storage done  there are several functions
that will work at the same time that they
will extract the audio from the videos with
ffmpeg then we will call the speech
which chirps to find the text and
the locations in fact of each word
in the video
of the text and then it  there is also the creation,
like me, of thumbnails to
have these images left there so
there are a whole bunch of videos that are
available just to show a little
bit of this diagram there so we have them
different functions we applaud a
video we will extract and transcode
the audio l'hérault then store it on
cloud storage
once we have the audio we will be
able to send it to la spezia and store the
transcription here and then at the bottom  we are
going to create we are going to retrieve an image from the
video to have the thumbnail this is
what this application does which is there and
so if I am we are watching I do not know
any video this one for
example we can go directly  also
has for example here I pressed if
I press seven and we can then
what is strong also is what I
like is that if I put what
can be common to all  a service or
something like that we will
also find we will finally be able to do
research in the videos and
find in which video like that there are
also services
so these are things that we can do
relatively easily by combining
different elements  different api
together and as  synchronized
each of the functions will do its
job according to the events it
receives here we are going to go back over the
slides thank you
different ue in this case these few
examples that I gave you my
different scenarios we will be able to
use the functions ago  many
services for example when
developers who use scorer who
want to be notified when there is a
pool request this is the kind of mechanism
that is used by d2
continuous web integration services or what is
called a url during  something has
finished we can call a
function http functions to do that for
small lots of countries we can also
use a function that is our
endpoint so all that event on a
little bit what we did here or also
what  'one did to extract for
example is labeled extract audio and
so it's doing a little bit of
it in a light way or as
obviously what is
typical event-driven  nt it's all
that is a tool we will see lots
of events coming from lots of
different devices which will be pushed
each time we have a sensor which will
give the new temperature etc
we can have events like that
that they are going to figure out who
triggered functions there I'm talking about
classes work in gcp but there is
also fire babes who also integrated
clac function so in addition to
events at cloud storage club
and then direct invocations http s it
there are also other events that are
available so for example when we
use the new fire
store database or the sybase
williams database in fact as soon as there is going to
be something that is going to be modified
updated and c  is in the
real-time database
we will be able to be notified or if
a user of your
mobile web application developed with fire bays
also authenticates we will be able to
be
we will be able to call our function  tion or
also if there is therefore there to rate
analytics if there is a goal a conversion
that has been made
once again we will be able to be
notified and then that is a subject that
I like is what you know
from haydock blur is the new name of the
piats is endowed with and perhaps we
know better and iaïdo dr therefore at ikea
of hazards and this is what makes it possible to make conve
sational interfaces for every
hing that is  each boots etc which is a
product that is part of who is
with us it's a product a company
that we had bought a year ago
something like that and in fact when we
finally have a user who will use for
example  google home with the
google actions integration for the
google assistant platform it will take a little
bit of business logic so I don't know
when we ask google chrome
what the weather is
it will tell us the weather but
they have to  go and look for this
information that makes this calculation or in
any case that it  calls the services to
do that and makes it an integration
now direct elsewhere in
the fuzzy dialogue interface which allows
to describe its functions
directly inside finally the console
of agglo closed but we can also
obviously put them  in
tomorrow's interface with club works
directly since in dawn of law well
I'm not going it's moreover in no I
'm not saying that then I'll show you
after on my computer
so we can what do I  wanted to
say by the way I don't know anymore
[Music]
well I'm going to move on I believe directly
to what I wanted to show you
so me for example for day 2 pi
it's March 14 and in those who don't know how
to write the dates in  united states
write 3.14 we wrote in
happiness 03/14/2010 is so day 3 14
was national or
international magpie day and i had made a little words
like that where in fact i use haydock
blurred  I created an agent with
blurry haydock that I have  i also deployed on
the interface on on the google assistant
and wanted so i can use it on
google voice au petit this little agent
allows to ask for the decimals of pi
so i will show it to you live here
then with the acoustic  it doesn't
always work
so don't blame me if the demo does
n't work ok google the skills and no
on the other hand it looks like it's not
connected hiccups gougaud has thus
limited
ok ok go go
knock knock by dj you  agent it starts well
ok google to which google docs all the
same digit agent
[Music]
what is from fortis and win digitalspy
15 euros it worked
thank you
we will look on my computer we will
pass on another small demo here I
will put  that in bigger buzz the
prettiest so in fact there I have my a
little less justice blurry dialogue
it's the 7 small interactions that game
that I developed and deployed and that
I integrated with the platform
google action and therefore I don't want to
rent  rer in the details and the concepts
of thailand vague but here I define
but interactions for example bolis
digitalspy etc and I will recover this
information me what interests me
it is the variables there I want to know
that it is finally the number 42
I want to be able to do something with it
is in fact here in blurred lofts we have
what is called the full feel man
this is what allows when there is a request
that is made by a user in fact
to call from the  business logic
somewhere that's going to process something is
actually what's going to happen is me
i'm going to recover so i want to know
what the 42nd
the forty second decimal of pi
is actually me behind i'm going to call a
service that  'we had deployed with
colleagues on gc pays and we had crunch
and cd with a tool called
foreign king we got hooked and we had
found I don't know how many we
had but millions and millions
of decimals of pi  is actually so  there
me what do I give in fact it allows me
the full feel man to define a web book
and what do I give as url I give
the url of my class works what
I deployed and if we look so that
's what  that I deployed in a
simulator to be able to test that I
do them directly on the machine on
google we are here here again
I deployed just a small function
that retrieves so I use the the the
node module which gives me  allows to be able to
interact with the google
assistant platform I retrieve the parameter the
rank in fact the number the rank of the
decimal and then I call myself here
below another api that we have developed which
allows to recover the luron and then I
say here is what
finally he will answer me the dj of 42 to
loot and that's what you want to
know more about it you want to stop and
then after I deployed export the
gites function and we find hop I
'm going to do like  the one here and we
find here there what I deployed u  p
the function that I deployed here
so here it is a small example but
it is true that it is a
slightly fashionable subject all that is flat
boots
I made a lot of presentation on the
on the subject and moreover as we launched
in French the action platform of
google
you can also write and create
your own vocal interactions for your
projects your brands etc
here we are going to go back to the slide we will
therefore conclude in summary the clouds  sanchez a
is the server solution the help
offered by google cloud platform for
this new unit of deployment
this new unit of measurement which is
application of business logics etc which
is of the order of the function where you no
longer need you  worry about
skiing and provisioning clusters
of vm servers etc.
you don't need to manage all these
servers there the scanning is done 2-0 to
n depending on the need
and then depending on this
use you will pay only this  why
in  end the resources you really have to
use the close also
event-oriented whether it's events
coming from the cloud or events that
you create yourself whether it's
also synchronous if you call as with
the little demo with the google men if
you call  a class works
http version and then so here is this
unit deploying the function and no
longer a big monolithic application
which has a whole bunch of other services
it's not the only server approach
leaves that we have within google cloud
platform
so  if you want to use
couriers to do your analytics if
you want to use
you said weisz aliotti who want to
exchange messages you can
use clad pub etc of the few you
can watch dig a little bit
more so there really are the
server comfortable  it's not just confident but
it's complicated and data 1 is in any
case the platform offers you a lot
of choices on this side there some small
p  anoint so if you want to learn
more and play with claude functions you
can go to clad google.com slash
ventures I believe that in the workshops
we have in the echo of the awb which are
not very far from here you  can
also train and play with the function
and then here at home you want to do
where at work there is a click works
you have 2 million free invocations per
month so for your tests
finally unless it's load tests
obviously  but for your tests and your
developments it won't cost you
anything if you do web mobile
you need interaction between
mobile devices etc you can use
club also works in
aspen fire games google.com and if you
want  find out more
generally about the close server leaves
we also have a dedicated page on the theme
of the server leaves what
is the server leaves here we are thank you
very much for your attention I think
we have
thank you  i
[Applause]